the new Call of Duty is go and it's a
whole three days early thanks to the
impatience of the Internet as a result
here's what we know so far about call of
duty advanced warfare a trusted source
told destructoid about the game subtitle
and also confirmed that Kevin Spacey
will be playing a role in the game a
leaked recording features the voice and
lightness of the a-list actor and his
involvement was confirmed through the
official call of duty Instagram account
according to sources the game will
revolve around a soldier of fortune
group headed up by Kevin Spacey's
character who's turned on the US
government predictably the game is going
to come out in November on the fourth if
you want to market in your calendars the
same source has said that the game will
include the ability for players to donít
exosuits which will let players jump
crazy high scale buildings and enable
cloaking and for something completely
different there will also apparently be
hoverbikes let me know what you think of
the trailer and advanced warfare as it
stands we will keep you updated on
gamespot.com of all the call of duty
goodness as it unfolds